you were a single attractive woman are
you out there dating how's it going no
count it yeah I just have to know yeah
there's nothing much to know I am single
and it's not been this guy yeah I I am
and it's not going you know too terribly
well and so that's luckily well it's not
going well Conan now tell you what this
is such a stupid thing for me to say but
that's what I do for a living I just
assume when someone's very attractive
that it would go that would go well well
I'll tell you a weird story actually
recently my cousin hooked set me up with
a date sort of situation was a blind
date I never met this guy before and we
were out to dinner and he said you know
in my early 20s I really felt like it
was important to be with somebody who
was really like a supermodel and and
skinny and beautiful and kind of like a
Victoria's Secret model and now in my
30s I really feel like it's more about a
personality not so much about looks and
that's why I'm so glad that I'm out here
with you I'm so glad you on this date
because your personality is so much more
than the way you look and I said you
can't say that out loud
you that's the inside head voice um but
he then the date actually got worse
because then it got worse from there
yeah yeah how does it get worse for you
freestyle wrapped to me
now in his defense that was my move back
at the day you know and did he really
freestyle rap oh yeah yeah and not well
I I know shocker but yeah he freestyle
raps and his name was well I won't tell
you his name but how it would be so
great
but he wanted me to call him you boy so
by the way I did not know this going on
the date this guy's in his 30s yes and
he wants to be called you boy yeah I'm
Star Trek's yes and I said you're not my
boy like whose boy is this uh I don't
know um but no his name was your boy he
had a real name but he wanted to know I
know that he had a real name I know that
I know that he was not his birth
certificate doesn't say you boy
oh I as well oh my god oh my god yeah
yeah so when are you seeing him again
that's my question he's my boyfriend
you took you to Long John Silver's you
have to see him again
you